[Music]
it what's up guys um could be HD here so
we've had 10 million subscribers on this
channel for a couple weeks now and it's
been pretty incredible still honestly
not really used to seeing that number
there it's a crazy amount of people but
this is a direct result of that you may
have seen it before or maybe you haven't
seen it or maybe this is the first time
we're seeing it in all this detail but
this comes straight from YouTube with a
note from Susan the CEO and it's the
award for hitting 10 million subscribers
on one channel it's the diamond play
button oh ok so as some of you may know
YouTube is one of the only platforms
that shows its appreciation for the
creators that make it possible in this
sort of physical way maybe the only
platform like they definitely don't do
everything right and they might have a
long way to go as far as earning
everyone's complete love and trust but
this is a genuinely cool thing that they
do that you don't see Instagram or
Facebook or tik-tok or other creator
driven platforms doing so this is cool
to see actually first there are some
other awards for some other milestones
that have changed over the years this is
the original silver hundred thousand
subscriber award milestone that I got
back I don't remember what year exactly
but as you can see nice little frame a
bowl certificate this is one of the
originals and then you get to adding a
digit alright and then you get this
gigantic million subscriber this is the
gold play button award and they put the
the logo from a channel down here and
this is Hannibal as well this I got in
2014 and this is also one of the
originals so I hadn't actually hung this
up on a wall yet in the studio just cuz
it's so heavy but as you could tell they
have a pretty similar look to each of
them but since then now they've updated
it so there's two newer more minimalist
ones still silver and gold but now
they're frameless they're clean and
they're probably also much easier to
hang I switched over to that a couple
years ago you know what I'm also going
to link below the like button what's
inside video where they toured the sort
of mini factory the facility where they
make these creator Awards but then we've
arrived at this so this is the YouTube
10 million subscriber diamond
play button it's not meant to be hung up
it's just a button this one as far as I
know has been unchanged since they
started making it and it also seems to
be the most exclusive one aside from the
custom 50 million and hundred million
subscriber awards I think only PewDiePie
has gotten but I feel like now that I
have it in person might as well review
it so without having it with you the
hardest thing to convey or see on camera
is how heavy like how dense it is
spoiler it isn't actually a giant
diamond but it is a solid piece of
machined aluminum which is super heavy
and then polished on the outside with
this crystal embedded in the middle of
it it's heavy it's hard to hold in one
hand and if I actually put it on the
scale it shows about 4800 grams or about
ten and a half pounds that's about the
same as a 2-liter soda or a large
watermelon or maybe for you tech people
330 inch MacBook Pros stacked on top of
each other and then some so that is the
number one thing that everyone will
notice but then of course what you can
tell is it's extremely shiny like it has
all kinds of angles to it and the whole
thing is very reflective which
ultimately makes it a fingerprint magnet
which explains the microfiber cloth that
actually comes in the briefcase when you
first take it out the box typically when
something is a fingerprint magnet this
much it's also slippery and you want to
like cover it up but I'm gonna say this
is not something you want to throw a
deep brown skin on you know show it off
prop it up somewhere that's why it has
the microfiber layer on the bottom of it
so that you can confidently put it down
and stand it up on its end because
unfortunately unlike the other two
awards there's pretty much no way to
hang this one on a wall on the back it
has the channel name and it says
congratulations on passing 10 million
subscribers and on the YouTube logo and
it's laser etched and in the crystal in
the middle I think it's pretty sick it
sticks out a bit like a camera bump on
the back of a phone but I'm not mad
about this one at all and it has a bunch
of cuts on the sides of it so the more
you tilt it around in the light the more
you get all kinds of different
reflections and it looks sick overall
design 9 out of 10
ergonomics I'm gonna give it like a 7
out of 10 build quality is a 10 for sure
and value is priceless seriously if you
haven't watched the previous the
million subscriber celebration video
just know that this of course would not
exist here without you guys and many of
the things I'm able to do on this
channel would also not be possible
without you guys I want to say there the
uploads are a little quiet in January
just because there's not that much tech
happening in January but the lineup for
February is already super sick and I'm
excited to share this stuff with you
guys and it's because of you that this
is all possible so thank you again for
subscribing thanks for watching I'll
catch you guys the next one pace